hi there Steve here continuing my 90 day
Korean challenge today I want to talk
about mistakes but first of all if you
enjoy these podcasts about language
learning please subscribe to my channel
mistakes you know yesterday oh and I
should say by the way I'm going to start
putting up these videos these
discussions that I've had with Hama in
Korea and I'll put one right up after
this one and maybe there's about four or
five that we've done and I'll schedule
them across the next ten days or so
those of you who speak Korean will hear
that I make mistakes in fact what's
interesting we had a discussion
yesterday and I was determined that I
was going to use this phrase which means
nevertheless which is coral meadow pool
Guha go Koroma do pull go go I had even
practiced it ahead of time because I had
heard it a number of times in the
podcast that I was listening to however
when it came time to use it
maybe because I had tried so hard to
remember it of course I got it wrong
I got a close I think I said credo pool
go go instead of coral meadow fool and
I'm going by memory and so the
interesting thing about mistakes is we
sometimes remember that we made a
mistake even though we made the mistake
we can be corrected and make the mistake
again we sometimes get it right one time
and get it wrong the next time so
mistakes are a sort of organic part of
speaking in a foreign language gradually
the number of mistakes we make gets
smaller most of the mistakes we make we
discover ourselves or through a lot of
exposure and use and listening and
reading we start we refine these
mistakes away mostly ourselves to some
extent correction can help although
there's a lot of research that shows
that it doesn't help a great deal I know
from personal experience that when I
correct people they come right back with
the same mistake I know for example with
my Russian tutor I'll make a mistake she
corrects it in my link you know report I
read it and yet the next time I speak I
get the same mistake corrected I just
can't seem to get that particular
expression or use of words or whatever
it is right that's absolutely normal and
and it's not because you get corrected
that you're gonna get it right and and
we don't know how I will take before you
are able to rid yourself of that pattern
that your brain has a tendency to go in
a certain direction some of the time
most of the time occasionally hit it
right
I always use the example of people who
speak English and despite the fact that
everyone knows at least theoretically
that it's the third person singular has
an S he goes he knows she does the
number of people who continue to say he
go she do you know because it takes a
long time to get rid of these mistakes
I don't consider making mistakes such a
big problem obviously if you are working
in my country and you're sending out
official correspondence you can't make
mistakes you have to have you have to be
so good that you don't make mistakes but
for most people who are learning
languages making mistakes is not a
problem and I don't mind exposing my
mistakes
so that's briefly now I mentioned that
because on our format link somebody
posted an article from Luca Lumpur
Yama's blog where he has a guest article
there by Anthony louder who is a person
who lives in Prague I gather speaks
Czech I've never heard him speak Czech
and I don't know if he speaks out their
languages but he is very active in the
sort of polyglot community and his
perspective always is that you don't
need many you don't need many words to
consider yourself fluent and so then and
that we should focus rather on being
fluent with a few words and I very much
disagree with this obviously language
learning is very much an individual
journey so everything depends on what
you want to do and if you live where the
language is spoken which was for me the
case when I lived in Japan then you
start speaking early again with mistakes
if you're studying away from where the
language is spoken then what you do
depends on what you feel like doing in
my own case I like listening and reading
because it enables me to engage
the language to engage with meaningful
content I measure how much I engage with
the language by the number of words that
link tells me I know those are passive
vocabulary items I don't hang my hat on
this as saying I know all these words
but what it tells me is that I have
spent so much time listening and reading
that the words that I haven't saved or
the words that I saved and then convert
it to known is this large number this
represents a major engagement with the
language now when I go to speak I'm
gonna make mistakes the more I speak the
better I get whether I choose to start
speaking early or late is a personal
decision but in this article of Anthony
laughter's he comes on very strongly to
say that you know in traditional
language instruction people used to
count words which of course is not true
traditional language instruction was
very much based on teaching grammar
rather than keeping track of known words
I believe that keeping track of known
words is a great sort of Gordian not
simple measurement of the extent to
which you have been engaged with the
language now if you haven't been writing
you won't be able to write well if you
even relied entirely on reading without
listening then your listening
comprehension won't be very good but
potentially if you have a large
vocabulary your ability your potential
ability to develop all of your language
skills is very high if for example you
have a great degree of fluency all
around very simple limited context then
it there's still a long road before
you'll be able to understand movies
understand podcasts read books on the
other hand if you are able to read a
novel in the language but don't speak
very well I think if you are committed
to speaking and you spend a lot of time
speaking your speaking will catch up
very quickly so I personally believe and
that's what we do at the link we say we
measure your known words that's the sort
of ultimate milestone
of how far you have progressed in the
language now if you want to improve in a
particular skill that you have to focus
on that skill I make a point of
listening even more than I read and I
read a lot because that way my brain is
also getting used to the language know
again logger goes on to say we should
rather than focusing on and he says that
the European framework of reference is
focusing more now on what you can do
with the language rather than on your
say word count but the point is if you
look at the advanced levels in the
European framework they all imply a
large vocabulary otherwise you can't
talk or write about subjects on a wide
range of issues you don't understand
them so B 2 C 1 C 2 requires a large
passive vocabulary not all of which
obviously you can activate lauder also
encourages us to spend time with these
scenarios pretending we're at the post
office pretending we're here pretending
we're there I have never found those
very a not very interesting to do I
would rather spend my time trying to
follow the recent political scandals in
Korea than practicing going to the post
office with the tutor either live or on
link or whatever but again this is
entirely a personal it depends on what
people want to do I believe that when I
have a real need to spend a lot of time
at Korean stores and post offices and
things of that nature that I will learn
that by going to those places and trying
to explain what I want and getting
answers that I don't understand and my
experience has been that even where I
have had this scenario of what they do
at the train station when I go to the
train station in fact the context is
quite different from my scenario so I
don't consider those things very you
know much fun to do and I don't find
them all that useful but if people want
to do that that's fine too so and and
the idea and he also makes the point
this lauder article on Luke in fact I'll
leave a little link to it he says there
are people with very large word counts
who when they speak the language they
stumble I don't know if he's referring
to me or someone who has used link and
has a high word count I have a high word
count in here
when I speak Korean I stumbled of course
I haven't spoken very much whenever you
go to speak
you're gonna stumble you're gonna make
mistakes it's normal to make mistakes
the more you speak the fewer mistakes
you make
however if you have a large vocabulary
then your ability to a comprehend what
the other person is saying and to
express and cover a large you knows more
interesting meaningful subjects in your
conversation rather than just sort of
the scenario of going to the post office
you know you're gonna be able to tackle
more satisfying authentic meaningful
subjects and the greater your passively
vocabulary in my opinion the more
confident you are even if you stumble
and struggle at least you understand
what the other person is saying but I I
want to make sure that that why I'm
saying this is I think language learning
is very much personal the fact that a
person has like I have large word count
in Korean I put up this video of myself
speaking Korean I struggle I make a lot
of basic mistakes so what that's me in
my language it's really not for others
to come along and say well he's not
really very good I'm not there to
perform in order to demonstrate that I'm
very good or not so good
you know look at me and in two months
I'm able to do all of this it's not that
it's demonstrating that that in fact it
takes a long time and I don't mind
showing you know my gradual progress
hopefully towards a better level and if
I speak more and if I could find more
people to talk to here then I would
speak better but that doesn't take away
from the enjoyment that I have I said
the other day I was in a restaurant some
people were speaking polish we didn't
speak much boys they quickly got back to
English good for me because I would
really stumbled in Polish but I can
listen to podcasts about world events in
Polish which gives me a great deal of
satisfaction so based on my needs here
in Vancouver that satisfies me if I were
in Poland for a month then my speaking
skills would improve although for the
first week two weeks three weeks I would
make a lot of mistakes and and I think
the making of mistakes is is it's just a
comes with the territory that's
basically part of
learning learning a language so there
you have it mistakes you don't correct
them right away I still believe that
vocabulary count as a measure of your
degree of engagement with the language
your potential with the language
many people say immigrants who are in
Canada and say you know I can read but I
can't speak very well say then if you
ask them well do you read novels when
you go home in the evening you watch
local television or do you watch
television or CDs from your home country
so if they're not engaging with the
language then their language potential
is going to be limited although they
might have perfected a routine for their
their basic needs whatever they may be
at the shop and stuff like that but
that's and maybe that's all I want to
achieve and then that's fine but then
let's not pretend that that some form of
fluency the fluency as I said before is
B 2 and better and to do that you need a
large vocabulary but you can make
mistakes and before you get the B 2
you're gonna make a lot of mistakes
anyway I kind of rambled a bit here but
it's a subject that comes up all the
time and now if you want to hang on you
can listen to my Korean discussion with
Hanna the first of many and you'll see
that I make a lot of mistakes if you're
familiar with the Korean language bye
for now